[Música]
un día mi mamá llegó llorando y me dijo
me voy a morir en nuestro país
me quedo igual que ustedes salar no será
cierto
mi nombre saldrá tamara sánchez soy
licenciado en electrónica estudiado aquí
en la benemérita universidad autónoma de
puebla estudio la gestión
experimentación y control y un doctorado
en propias eléctricas de materiales
aunque no aparezca solo
esta nueva de la fotografía con
numeritos de licenciado en electrónica
aquí en la universidad
acá me ubico yo me ubico inventar cosas
así desarrollo tecnología luego en
diferentes áreas una de las empresas
industriales donde desarrolló e inventó
cosas para alimentos ahora traen robots
principalmente robots o manuel 21 lo que
hago es desarrollo hermanos robóticos
con 12 15 grados de libertad y el
enfoque es que en un futuro pueden ser
utilizado como prótesis y también
desarrollo cosas también invento cosas
en la glo neutrónica esta plática es uno
de esos inventos que he desarrollado en
esta área de la vio electrónica
para poder contestar se para poder darle
una respuesta en el mar
ir a dar una necesidad social puesto que
además estábamos preocupada para que si
va a morir por nuestro perro sis me puse
a investigar es la primera parte que
siempre no debe hacer que nuestro polo
sis pues una enfermedad de los huesos
que provoca una disminución de la masa
ósea es decir de la densidad ósea y se
verá un deterioro del tejido social
aumentando las fracturas tengo futuras
es algo muy importante
en la misma búsqueda de información
encontró que las mujeres son más
susceptibles a contraer esta enfermedad
17 por ciento de las mujeres lo contraen
nadie por ciento de los hombres lo
encontraron números de 50 años esto
quiere decir que en méxico tenemos 24
millones de personas que pueden ser
susceptibles a contraer esta enfermedad
con esto la respuesta no te vas a morir
pero tarde o temprano te vas a caer y
cuando te caigas te vas a romper es
decir te vas a fracturar en el
dominicano del seguro social
ha reportado que pacientes con fractura
de cadera tiene un costo hospitalario de
5 mil 100 dólares
si tenemos 24 millones de personas
susceptibles a esta enfermedad imaginen
menos cuántos pacientes vamos a tener
que hospitalizar por fractura de cadera
fractura de vértebra o fractura de
muñeca
toda enfermedad tiene una parte
preventiva en una parte correctiva
en las políticas de salud pública
se enfocan principalmente a la
prevención
una forma algo importante que me
gustaría que quedara claro es que la
prevención para nuestro poder si se es
algo muy simple
tan simple como esto realmente tenemos
que tener una dieta sana tenemos que
comer una dieta sana y rica en calcio y
fósforo
leche de soya tortillas huevos carne
todo aquello que siempre tenemos que
comer normalmente
no debemos consumir vitamina do porque
no encontramos nuevos encontramos
también en carne no sobre todo en baños
de sol
vayámonos a la playa o por lo menos a la
alberca y esto nos va a ayudar a que en
un futuro no nos dé osteoporosis
algo importante es no fumar
no consumir en exceso bebidas
alcohólicas no consumir en exceso
cafeína no consumido en exceso sal
miembro también últimamente ha estado
pasando los evitar pérdidas de peso en
exceso
normalmente los jóvenes están muy
preocupados por cómo se ven están muy
preocupados por perder peso
esa actividad de perder peso puede tener
graves consecuencias en el futuro
pero no es importante
diagnosticar la enfermedad es importante
y como lo diagnosticamos cómo ayudamos a
prevenir esa enfermedad
en otras palabras como hacen en nuestro
país
hay varias técnicas
es utilizando comercialmente una técnica
de rayos x
y otra es por otra sonido determinando
la velocidad a la cual una onda acústica
atraviesa el hueso
dependiendo de la densidad del hueso es
la velocidad es el trazo nido y también
existen técnicas de marcadores químicos
biológicos estas técnicas además de
determinar la densidad del hueso también
nos dice la razón de por cual se está
tomando ese deterioro del hueso
la pregunta para todo investigador
existe algo más para medir densidad ósea
pues sí
yo estudié un doctorado en propiedades
web ticas y por lo tanto
toda una idea toda una hipótesis que por
conductivo de la lógica es posible medir
densidad ósea que es la conductividad
óptica con la propiedad que tiene toda
la materia para conducir corriente
cuando se le aplica un voltaje que
signifique esto algo no sé si nosotros
hacemos la materia si nosotros metemos
los datos dentro de un contacto lógico
que tiene voltaje lo más seguro es que
circula corriente a través de nuestro
cuerpo
y eso lo querían los topes que es lo
importante de este fenómeno
yo puedo meter mis dedos y va a conducir
una cierta valor de corriente pero en
joven de 20 años va a ser lo mismo y en
valor de corriente va a ser diferente lo
mismo sucede con una persona de 100
kilos la corriente también anima ser
diferente esto quiere decir que la
conductividad eléctrica es exclusiva
para cada persona
un color ario cuando nosotros vamos a
dar
a la cantina exigen a nuestro objetivo
pero también exigiendo a nuestros papás
no sé si se han preguntado por qué razón
muchas personas soportan más toques que
otras no precisamente por la
conductividad eléctrica unas personas
sean más susceptibles a conducir
corriente eléctrica y otras menos las
que conducen menos con este cuadrante la
aplicaciones que más aguantan
con este principio entonces nuestro para
precisos yo parlamentos y vertical
huyendo con motivo de la chica un parto
de un 8 de que un hueso sano tiene
diferente conductividad eléctrica abrazo
con nuestro país
por lo tanto nuestra propuesta es muy
sencilla colocamos elektra 2 ayuda del
brazo aplicamos voltaje medimos
corriente pero se salva la información a
través de modelos matemáticos un poco
complicados uno obtenemos lo que
necesitamos la medición de la
conductividad un luego con relacionamos
con el correspondiente valor de densidad
ósea
con esta propuesta después de algo
trabajo después de ocho años después de
dos estudiantes doctorados titulados uno
de los estudiantes también ingresado de
aquí la universidad de la mina de este
pueblo los premios en eventos nacionales
artículos científicos patente ante el
impi logramos nuestro propósito inventar
un sistema medido de densidad ósea con
las tres pes producción pre diagnóstico
y portátil
como aquellas derrotas aunque los pro
picando acerca de un dispositivo lo que
realmente les platiqué es el proceso del
cómo creamos ese dispositivo es un
proceso de cómo le hacemos para inventar
cosas si se fijaron nuestro primer lo
primero que necesitamos para poderlo
inventarios cuál es el problema
cuál es la necesidad ahora en una muy
clara la universidad cuando mi mamá me
dijo que se iba a morir porque te años
toporo sis y ahí empieza entonces la
curiosidad identificamos el problema y
encontramos muchos problemas un problema
nuestro para dosis los una
en que es un problema de salud pública
encontramos que hay prevención para los
troperos ys encontramos que se retienen
instrumentos para medir para monitorear
s osteoporosis y por lo tanto hicimos
una propuesta en contra de acuerdo a
nuestra formación y recuerdo mucho
trabajo obtuvimos nuestro diseño
obtuvimos nuestro prototipo y obtuvimos
nuestra protección industrial lo que
debe continuar es lo que llamamos
innovación lo que debe continuar la
comercialización pero eso es otra
historia como diría mi abuelita nosotros
nos quedamos con el proceso de creación
del proceso de cómo desarrollar cómo
inventar cosas
con esto y creo que son solo creativo y
lo duro porque en todo porque porque me
gusta dar solución a los problemas algo
importante es cuando lo aprendo la mente
lo pendiente durante el transcurso de
ninguna para iniciar cuando estudie la
electrónica aquí en la benemérita
universidad autónoma de puebla
la formación que me dieron no duran las
herramientas para iniciar este proceso
creativo en este proceso de inventar
cosas y ciertamente
pero esto también es como una pequeña
ayuda de los amigos donde pequeños
amigos tanto de la licenciatura como de
la maestría de como de doctorado como
carlos colegas habrá colegas que me
ayudaron a desarrollar y listo con este
dispositivo y de toda la gente exhibió
involucrado en este proceso
y un consejo que yo puedo darles una
recomendación es que si tú eres creó
todo un posgrado puede ser todo estimó
si eres emprendedor ser emprendedor
puede ser tu camino pero lo importante
y es la preparación el rumbo lo deciden
ustedes por la preparación que necesitan
es así la deben de tomar
y para los que no son creativos
también está el otro también la
recomendación es todo con el balance
duerman no fumen y como diría una bolita
otro baile indica otro gallo nos cantara
lo que lo mismo si secado no se van a
romper se van a levantar
muchas gracias por su atención
[Música]